♪♪
Narrator: IS THERE REALLY
ONLY ONE WAY TO COOK UP LIFE?
COULD LIFE FORM FROM A DIFFERENT
SET OF INGREDIENTS?
SCIENCE FICTION WRITERS
HAVE SPECULATED WILDLY
ABOUT ALTERNATIVE LIFE-FORMS,
BUT IN THE COLD,
HARD WORLD OF SCIENCE,
WE ONLY HAVE PROOF OF LIFE
AS WE KNOW IT.
BUT IF AN OCEAN
REALLY IS CRITICAL,
DOES IT HAVE TO BE
AN OCEAN OF WATER?
THAT'S A QUESTION
THAT DRIVES NASA'S CHRIS McKAY.
McKay: WHAT I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN FINDING
IS WHAT I CALL
A SECOND GENESIS OF LIFE,
ORGANISMS THAT ARE CLEARLY NOT
RELATED TO ANY LIFE ON EARTH.
ALL LIFE ON EARTH IS RELATED
TO ITSELF, FORMS A SINGLE TREE.
YOU CAN CALL THAT LIFE ONE.
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
IS LIFE TWO --
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT RELATED.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE PROFOUNDLY
DIFFERENT, BUT IT HAS TO BE
DIFFERENT ENOUGH THAT WE CAN SAY
WITH VERY HIGH CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY ARE NOT RELATED TO US,
WE DO NOT HAVE
A COMMON ANCESTOR.
♪♪
Narrator: WHERE SUCH A LIFE-FORM
COULD FEASIBLY EMERGE
WAS ANYONE'S GUESS.
UNTIL, IN 2005,
THE WORLD'S ATTENTION
TURNED TO TITAN,
THE BIGGEST OF THE MOONS
WHICH ORBIT AROUND SATURN.
AT THAT TIME,
ALL WE KNEW OF IT WAS
THAT IT LOOKED GASSY,
ORANGE, AND LIFELESS.
WE KNEW THAT TITAN WAS
A FUZZBALL FROM TELESCOPES.
BEFORE A SPACECRAFT
EVER WENT TO TITAN,
JUST LOOKING AT TITAN
WITH A TELESCOPE,
WE COULD TELL THAT IT HAD
A THICK ATMOSPHERE.
♪♪
Narrator: BUT THEN IN 2005,
THE CASSINI-HUYGENS PROBE
PASSED BY,
REVEALING A SURFACE
THAT WAS UNEXPECTEDLY EARTHLIKE.
IT WAS DOTTED
WITH HUGE BODIES OF WATER,
BEARING AN UNCANNY GEOGRAPHICAL
SIMILARITY TO THE GREAT LAKES.
McKay: SO, VISUALLY,
WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE IMAGES
OF THE LAKES, WE SEE REFLECTIONS
OF WHAT WE SEE IN AIRPLANES
WHEN WE LOOK DOWN
AS WE FLY OVER THE GREAT LAKES.
Narrator: THERE WAS ONE CRUCIAL
DIFFERENCE, THOUGH --
THESE WEREN'T LAKES OF WATER.
THEY WERE LAKES OF METHANE
AND, AT -292 FAHRENHEIT,
THEY'RE TOO COLD
FOR ANY LIFE-FORM
WITH AN EARTH-LIKE CHEMISTRY.
McKay: I WOULD CONTEND THAT WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE ROLE
OF TEMPERATURE DIRECTLY IN LIFE.
NOW, ON EARTH, OF COURSE,
WE'RE USED TO LIVING
IN A HIGH-TEMPERATURE LIQUID
AT HIGH TEMPERATURE.
WE'RE IN THE FAST LANE.
WE METABOLIZE VERY RAPIDLY
BECAUSE WE'RE LIVING
AT HIGH TEMPERATURE, RIGHT?
WELL, ON TITAN, THE LIQUID
THAT'S THERE IS COLD,
THE TEMPERATURES ARE COLD.
IF THERE'S LIFE THERE,
IT'S OBVIOUSLY IN THE SLOW LANE.
IT'S METABOLIZING VERY SLOWLY,
BUT SO WHAT? WHAT'S THE RUSH?
THERE'S NOT AN ABSOLUTE TEMPO
THAT LIFE MUST KEEP TO.